SCP-682 Vs SCP-093.
Our dimension can’t seem to keep the Hard
to Destroy Reptile down, but maybe the dimension
that SCP-093, the Red Sea Object, offers us
access to across the mirror plane might have
better luck?
The object passed around SCP-682 until it
turned green and affixed itself to a nearby
mirror, purposefully selected to be big enough
to allow SCP-682 through.
When it refused to enter, the mirror was brought
over, 682 was pushed in, and then the mirror
was shattered.
However, later on, the mirror anomalously
put itself back together and SCP-682 was pushed
back out - Because of course he was.
SCP-682 commented, of his time on the other
side:
“'I am not very amused.”